all might versus all for one just went
nuclear as the world's greatest hero
prepares to sacrifice everything for the
Next Generation all for one has become
unhinged and all might is trying to use
that to his Advantage but all for once
current state of mind could just as
easily bring about the destruction of
all might Deku and all of Japan the mha
climax is insane so let's get into it
you guys know how this works if you
enjoy my mha content and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now it helps me out a
lot with that YouTube algorithm and if
you want to help us attain Quirk
Awakening on this channel by hitting 2
million subscribers do me a big favor
and subscribe right now we are
approaching that 2 million Mark and
every single subscription counts finally
this video will of course contain bokuro
hero manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned in the
previous chapter all might dawned his
superpower Iron Man armor and became
Iron might this armor is Cutting Edge
Tech created by David and Melissa shield
and it was specifically designed to
allow the now kirkless all might to
fight powerful multiple Quirk users like
all for one the armor has a whole bunch
of special abilities that are actually
based on the quirks possessed by Deku
and all might's other students and so
the armor effectively allows all mine to
use the equivalent of multiple quirks at
the same time we saw him using abilities
similar to deku's Black whip Sarah's
tape sato's Sugar Rush and kaminari's
electrification all my strategy is to
use multiple unique abilities in
combination with each other in order to
outsmart and outmaneuver all for one and
so far he's been doing an effective job
all might also knows that all for one is
currently far less calm and far more
emotionally unstable than usual and the
hero is trying to use that to his
Advantage he wants to buy time for Deku
by manipulating all for one into
fighting his old rival instead of
heading out to locate shigaraki as soon
as possible all might also wants to
trickle for one into making mistakes and
Reckless Decisions by provoking him into
becoming even more angry and emotional
it's been absolutely awesome seeing all
might in action once again especially
since this is not just some like minor
battle with low stakes this is an
extremely important fight against the
arch villain over one himself and seeing
almight using shoot style to smash all
from one in the face at the end of the
last chapter was not only epic but also
heartwarming even though all might was
the greatest hero in history and even
though he was a teacher at UA he is
still actively learning from his own
students and he is incorporating their
fighting styles and techniques into his
own fighting style that shows how much
all might appreciates and respects his
students the latest chapter starts off
with all might still holding the
advantage in the fight primarily due to
the impressive power of his armor and
other support items this is the kind of
power that all for one simply wasn't
counting on because for all for one it's
all about quirks the villain severely
underestimated all might due to him
being quirkless and he is definitely
paying the price right now the hero
continues his strategy of trying to
provoke All For One by mocking him and
he says that this feels wrong because a
man who is over 55 years old shouldn't
be beating up a young man meaning the
de-aged all for one all might believes
that all for one fell victim to his
emotions and especially the hatred he
tried to cultivate in order to one day
steal one for all as we know after
generations of failing to steal one for
all all for one concluded that only
someone with immense hatred will be able
to overwhelm the vestiges and steal one
for all all might feels that he can use
this hatred to his Advantage by
provoking all for one until he loses a
school and makes a costly mistake so all
might continues pounding on all for one
while mocking him at the same time time
he says Demon Lord that's the funniest
joke I've ever heard even a quirkless
man can take you head on this
provocation hits deep because all for
one had always dreamed of becoming a
super villain Demon Lord ever since he
was a kid who read comic books all for
one is clearly triggered by this insult
and he uses like six different quirks at
once which causes a massive explosion of
power that destroys multiple large
buildings in the process all might
survives the explosion by engaging his
protective utility Cape whose power has
been nicknamed the dark shadow in honor
of tokoyami the cape itself is severely
damaged by the explosion but it has done
its job and all mine is able to continue
fighting although he did suffer some
injuries on his left wrist and
collarbone despite taking some damage
almight is pleased because he can tell
that his taunts are working when all for
one activated those six quirks at once
it was clear that he was just combining
them at random before now he would
always use carefully thought out and
pre-planned Quirk combos but now he is
no longer his normal cold and
calculating self he is clearly angry and
unhinged and instead of planning out his
moves he is throwing out wild Hail Mary
attacks all might activates maximum
motion assist on his armor in order to
compensate for the damage he sustained
and then he continues to engage all for
one head on which genuinely surprises
the villain all for one is confident in
his belief that the quirkless
middle-aged all might is nothing but a
worthless piece of trash and he doesn't
know why wearing an Iron garbage bag has
suddenly given the hero all this
confidence as soon as the villain is
able to significantly damage the Armor
All might will be done for unlike a
person in their Quirk a suit of armor
cannot surpass its limits once it cracks
and breaks it's useless but Almighty is
fully aware of this and he knew all of
this coming into the fight we then see a
quick flashback of what might be the
very very first time toshinori met his
master Nana shimura as Nana is taking
down a bunch of villains she turns and
sees a boy standing behind her this is
toshinori back when he was still
quirkless but even though he was
quirkless he was holding a metal pipe in
his hands and attempting to help by
beating the villains with the pipe
toshinori looks up at the floating Nana
with great admiration and this could be
the very moment he decided to become a
pro hero just like Nana to me this looks
like one of the first moments the two of
them ever met because if you look at
their expressions they don't seem to
know each other and it would make sense
if this was how they met this kind of
reminds me of all might witnessing Deku
trying to save bakugou despite being
quirkless so this could be the moment
when Nana first noticed toshinori as he
tried to fight against a bunch of
dangerous villains despite being
quirkless back in the present all might
throws a punch right at over one's
forehead but this time the villain
doesn't seem to be affected he looks at
all might with deranged eyes and tells
him that he won't fall for the hero's
pathetic plan all for one says that his
victory is assured and that he has
plenty of time to take out the trash but
almight isn't giving up as more support
items seem to fly up towards him all
might Roars stop making excuses honestly
it's embarrassing and that is how this
chapter comes to an end this was another
intense and interesting chapter and all
my strategy of provoking all for one
definitely seems to be working tsukauchi
and the cops thought that all for one
would wreck all might in a matter of
seconds but here we are quite some time
later and not only is all might holding
his own but he is successfully
pressuring all for one into losing his
cool and making Reckless moves like
firing off 6 random quirks at once all
might is learning from his students he's
combining different powers in smart and
strategic ways and he is successfully
getting under over one's skin logically
all for one should be on his way to
locating shigaraki right now but he
isn't and that alone means that all
might is winning at least for now
however if you look carefully this
chapter may be a lot deeper and a lot
more tragic than it appears at first
glance there are some serious potential
death Flags here for all might and the
theory that all might is about to
sacrifice his life for the next
generation is becoming more and more
believable with each passing chapter
last chapter we were reminded of Sir
Knight eyes prophecy that almight would
die in a brutal battle against a villain
and in this chapter we saw almight
mentioning how he's already an older man
who's lived a sizable accomplished life
as if to remind us that if he dies now
it won't be so bad we also had important
aspects of his life literally flashing
before his eyes as we saw with the Nana
flashback many decades ago toshinori was
the quirkless kid who does desperately
wanted to become a hero but now there is
a new generation ready to take his place
including Deku and all the other hero
students that all might loves and
respect so much that he based his armor
suit powers on their quirks it really
does feel like almight's character Arc
is coming full circle and reaching its
natural conclusion he is passing the
Baton to the Next Generation so yeah all
might may be about to make the ultimate
sacrifice Right Here and Now Against All
For One thereby fulfilling sir Knight
eyes prophecy but even if he does die
here almight knows that there are worthy
Heroes of the Next Generation who will
take his place and take care of Japan
after he is gone that said though I
don't want to make it sound like all
my's death is inevitable or anything
because it's not I also thought that
endeavor dying together with Dobby in
their fiery battle would be the most
powerful conclusion to his complex
character Arc but as of right now it
looks like Endeavors arrived albeit just
barely we can't assume that someone as
important as all might will really die
but it's definitely a possibility and I
think that horikoshi wants us to think
that the symbol of peace may not be long
for this world whether that's good
foreshadowing or misdirection only time
will tell okay real talk time I need you
guys to call it down in the comments
does all for one win this does all might
win or do they both take each other out
also could almight's taunting evolve for
one potentially backfire the more
unhinged all for one becomes the more
destructive he is going to become so if
he's pushed too far he might end up
destroying an entire city or something
before he finally goes down let's hope
all might doesn't just make over one mad
but then loses and all for one still
gets to deck when shigaraki only he's
more angry and unhinged than ever before
that would be bad for everyone involved
especially with all the quirks that all
for one still has in his possession if
you enjoyed this mha video don't ignore
my epic mha playlist that will keep you
swimming in heroes and villains while
you wait for the next Manga chapter to
draw if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like to let me know and if you are
one of the over 50 of people who watch
my videos but haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a big favor and
subscribe right now we are trying to
awaken the full potential of our Quirk
here on the channel by hitting 2 million
subscribers so every single subscription
counts